uh thank you everyone for uh joining us
today i'm really pleased to be able to
present
um our journey um into
into data really for the dcc um
we we started a few years ago and uh
it's been a really interesting journey
and we've enjoyed it all the way but
firstly i'd like to say thank you to
everyone
for joining us uh it's really great to
be
part of this community um we've had a
lot of help along our way
um and it's nice to sort of uh give
something back
uh on top of that i'd like to say thank
you to our studios uh they've been a
fantastic help
all along and uh the the journey
couldn't have been done without them
uh my name is oliver bridges i'm head of
data science at the
uh dcc and i'm going to show you
our journey from having a few canned
reports
through to having a team of 16 data
science
data wranglers and report writers and
and how we've progressed through that so
um
the first couple of slides are um
a little bit complex and a little bit
wordy so i apologize for that
please bear with me we'll get on to
the data the science side of things
uh very quickly but i just would like to
set the scene of what the smart dcc done
why we've had to make some of the
decisions that that we have so
um let's go on to the first slide
um as i said i'm head of data science at
the data community
communications company the dcc it's
important to understand what the dcc
is we're a licensed and regulated body
that was set up
and establish the
uh the united kingdom to roll up mark
meters
across the country um we were
set up and licensed by bays which is a
government department
so our license was enacted
as part of parliament and we are
regulated by uh the energy
uh watchdog ofgem who who watch out
forever
the license started in 2013
but we didn't start installing meters
until about 2017
and one of the most important things to
consider as part of our journey
is that we we are scrutinized with every
cost we have we have a price control
and everything must be agreed with our
stakeholders
and also our customers our stakeholders
being the government
and uh the uh off gem and our customers
being the energy suppliers the network
operators
so our network is the network that
connects
these smart meters across the country to
the
the users of the system and at the
moment we've got about
13 million meters that are connected
uh across the solution uh with that will
rise to about 50 million meters and
about 250 million
connected devices that will be on our
network
so really we're a very large-scale iot
solution um our whole network is rolled
out
by our service providers so the dcc
themselves
do not provide any infrastructure or any
um
kit really we manage our service
providers
who do that um at the moment we have
about 15 million messages across our
network every day so it's
quite a busy network but on top of that
we also have all the inventory
uh data that is there to support all of
that
at go live um we everything was
outsourced as i said
including our analytics so the dcc did
not provide any analytics at that point
but um we did we were mandated to have a
reporting
uh was responsible for governing and
distributing the
producer reports but they would check
the
qa check them and as part of this they
would have uh
sql access into it so just a little bit
of sql just enough to go in and check
that our reports were right but we did
not
have an analytics function but now we've
grown from a team of four to sixteen
we've taken all the analytics in-house
now so the dcc provides it all
it's been a journey to get there and
i'll take you through that
step uh flex data set
and what feels like a large data set as
well
and it's growing all the time as we get
busier and busier and more
installs happen we've also got a huge
customer base where we've got over 100
customers that we have to satisfy
um across the solution and they all use
it in a slightly different way
so that's where we are now the next
slide
will show up excuse me the next slide
we'll try and show you the landscape
that we're operating in so i'm going to
explain this diagram it's a little bit
complicated
uh from left to right so on the left
hand side is
is the home and this is where smart
meters sit and smart meters are
installed to
to enable people to have greater
functionality
at the uh local end of the electricity
market
so within a an electric meter
and a gas meter you'd also see in-home
display and this allows the user
to see how much electricity or gas
they're using or what tariffs they're on
or any
interesting information but there's also
a number of other smart devices that
would be in the home
including pre-payment devices and
devices to enable electric vehicles
all of this is installed within the home
and that's what
one of our day jobs is to ensure that
the installation of these meters takes
place
and these devices communicate via what's
called a comms hub
so on the left hand side within the home
all those devices and there's a comm sub
and that
that allows communication both within
the home but also via a wide area
network
uh back out to our users and if you look
at the
the middle piece there that describes
our network so we've got communication
service providers data service providers
and a whole host more
there's eight shown there but in reality
there are 15 at the moment and that will
be moving up
to about 40 by the time the solution is
complete
and on the far right hand side are our
customers who who communicate with the
meters or
receive communications from the meters
and these are the energy suppliers the
people who supply energy to the home
also the network operators
and there is the ability for authorized
third parties that might be
a comparison website for instance who
might want to
take some meter readings and recommend
the best tariff from the best provider
that is our ecosystem that that we're
working with and it is a complex one
so the next slide my team specifically
asked me to
to bring this in because it
is complex data that we're dealing with
um if you look there that's
a a map of all the installs just on one
day so that was the number of meters and
where they were installed one day and
actually this is taken
from one of our applications uh that
we we utilize um
that means we've got an ever-growing
base of
devices out there that are communicating
across our network growing by about
20 000 a day and that means
our the volume of data we're dealing
with is growing and you can see there
just last month we were over half a
billion records
in a month that we need to process and
analyze to provide results
to our hundred plus customers and this
creates
a complex data set there's all the
transactional data but on top of that
there's the data that supports those
transactions the inventory data
and why does this get complicated well
smart meters
have protocols that allow them to
communicate and there's a 127
different types of message that can be
sent across the network
those messages might vary from a meter
read to a firmware update
or a certificate swap and all those
messages come across our network they
vary in size
and some of them have to be sent in a
specific order
to allow them to be processed so there's
a complicated series of messages
that goes across the network we
mentioned earlier about our
infrastructure is
complicated technical solution uh that
means that the data that maps to it is
complicated and we have to
map that all together and finally
there's our users how are they using the
solution
they're all using it differently so we
have to understand what the difference
between our
100 plus users and how they're using it
and how we report on that data
to them and to our governing bodies and
uh and to government so our data
is large and complex
so to go through the journey that i
talked about earlier from
outsourcing our um our analytics
function to taking it in-house
go back to 2017 when our first
meters were were installed and we
we finally had a live solution um
at that point we provided 22 canned
reports that were provided by a service
provider and we had four engineers
who were there to ensure that they were
distributed
correctly and they had uh the correct
data in them so they had
some sql access uh that allowed them to
look at it but
but the reality was they weren't set up
as an analytics function they were a
reporting function
but of course once we went live with
more and more meetup has been
installed on our network a brand new
multi-billion pound
programming the program the data
questions started coming in
so uh as those data questions came in we
tried to sort of um
service those but we weren't set up for
that
that type of reporting but we did start
creating some some
some reporting some additional reporting
beyond what we were mandated to do as
part of our contract
but a backlog started building up then
in 2018 we
uh the dcc formed a new
um a new service called the talk the
technical operations center this was
stood up
to allow the dcc to monitor the solution
end-to-end
and the reason for this was that our
service providers were all mandated
to manage their their own piece of the
network but no one was looking
end to end to see how the end-to-end
service was
was performing were our customers
getting what they needed out of it so
the talk was stood up
and four new staff came in and we
brought a visualization
tool in with us and suddenly we had
some capabilities to allow us to perform
some complex analytics and
produce some more reports but of course
as we got more tools to answer data
questions even more data questions came
in
so by 2019
the analytics tool was now dealing with
one million plus rows of data
the visualizations were taking an hour
two hours several hours
to run and the analytics that we were
being asked to answer
were becoming more and more complicated
and those data questions just
did not stop coming but
the visualization tool we noticed had an
r
plug-in and this really was where our
journey transitioned
within the team by this point we're a
team of eight we decided perhaps we'd
better
learn our none of us had our we had some
basic sql or
or varying levels of sql uh around the
team some of us have been
linux scripters some of us had some
experience uh
in other programming languages so so we
2019
we downloaded our we got our studios and
our studio desktop and the the freeware
that's available to download and i must
warn anyone who's thinking of doing this
once you start there you won't stop it
is a gateway drug
and uh you know we're all addicts now
and we sit there
every day um working on our studio but
but it was a fantastic moment for us
and especially once we plugged that in
with connectivity into our
database using dbi we suddenly had the
ability to do
a lot more with the data that we wanted
and we could do it programmatically as
well
we were still dealing with very large
data sets
and at this point eventually we we
stumbled across
across data table which is fantastic i
love data table
it's got a bit of a very hard syntax to
follow
but it is so fast it's unbelievable
um i've put there that we started
dealing with 10 million rows
of data i think we're up to about 100 in
data table now
and we're doing some incredible stuff
that you just wouldn't believe with it
um and then on top of that we started
using um
shiny for dashboards but of course
we were only on the desktop version so
any dashboards that we wanted to show
off
that meant that people had to have r
studio installed and r
and everything else so it really wasn't
sort of um
something that we could push out across
our whole company
but we were using shiny we loved it we
couldn't believe what we could do with
it
but again data questions more data more
data more data
so in 2020 just over a year ago we
signed our commercial license with
um our studio and it's one of the best
things we've done
i'll thank our studio quite a few times
doing this but they were very patient
with us
as i said we we have a complex license
uh
that means that we we had a few asks as
part of the contract
they were very patient with us and just
over a year ago i know that because
we've just
renewed our license we we signed
the the deal to get our studio and of
course uh
with our studio team you you're now open
up
to uh having workbench
connect and package manager
and we got all of that um and we at the
same time we expanded from
8 to 16 bodies so that's roughly what we
are now
16 people within the team we also
migrated our
database to the cloud to be closer to
the processing so everything is
cloud-based and that might be the next
part of our journey how we expand that
we're still on sql server at the moment
but we also got our first um
contractual delivery something we've got
paid for rather than just
helping our customers out and uh we now
produce a
monthly 500 page pdf with a lot of the
processing done
within our studios we still visualize
for our visualization
tool um that that is a huge report that
takes
uh days of processing we're we're
aggregating you know half a billion
records
uh as part of that and it's very well
received by our customers
now i'll talk you through each of the uh
parts of uh our studio team
starting with our studio workbench um
as i've said all the heavy lifting is
done there this is where we sit
we're logged on all day uh utilizing it
i've got to call out whoever put the
the rainbow braces in as uh 1.4 of that
we we do love that
uh and and there's new functionality
being brought in
all the time our regular reports have
increased from
22 to 150 and that's increasing
all the time as there's more and more
demand
for um analytics from our team uh
we also take advantage of the um git
integration and that's
fabulous because we really are on an
evolution
and before we had that our version
control
needed to be improved um before we had
oh sorry just a little bit of feedback
but i'll carry on
um we're not just creating reports and
analytics there's all sorts of
hypothesis testing statistical inference
and uh
forecasting that we're doing with some
ml uh
below i've given just a rough idea of of
how we um utilize uh our workflow so
we'll schedule our reports with cronar
we know that we perhaps should be doing
that via
our markdown but we're very familiar
with it uh
as i said we interface with the database
using dbi
we then wrangle with the data using data
table
tidy verse deployer and there's a big
debate within my team
over who likes to use what but with the
large scale we
we end up putting everything in a data
table and of course you can then use all
the tidy verse functions
on top of that data table just like a
data frame uh and
ggplot's called out there separately
from the rest of tidy verse
we'll generally create our
visualizations with ggplot
um as i said our studio workbench
it really is the workhorse of everything
we do
but um the next
connect is really the uh
the the glory of everything we do this
is what people get
to see uh utilizing connect and of
course this is what we didn't
have um during whilst we were just
on the desktop so with connect
we managed to create a monitoring
dashboard and this
dashboard allows us to measure
analyze and report on over three
thousand metrics every five minutes
there's a rag
status uh that we put to it and if it's
red
or amber then we'll send out an email
and people can see it on the dashboard
as well
and it's all totally configurable we can
configure the
the metrics we're reporting on and also
who their sort of
emails etc will go down we also use
connect for
um parameterized reports with markdown
pins we're really starting to get into
pins and also apis
um apis allow us to um
really publish a single version of the
truth and that was one of the biggest
problems we
we had in the beginning was that you
could write sql
to get an answer any way you wanted to
know those answers would be different
they'd be equally correct
uh but but now we can publish things
both
externally and internally with with apis
pins we've we've started really using
and putting data sets there that we can
share
all this beautiful aggregated data that
takes two or three hours to
to to combine together and get the
results out we can then pin it and
other teams external to us can utilize
that data
we've also got our access portal so
instead of people coming to us and
asking for data
we can distribute that data to them and
we can
we can do it uh with access control so
different people see different data
and and that's all handled as part of
connect
we are we're also really starting to
turn into an application support team as
well because
because of this huge infrastructure that
we've built
with our studios teams we we need to
monitor it
each report that runs we need to know
what it's produced has it failed
all of that is built in with more shiny
dashboards
so just down the bottom now i've
mentioned a few of our favorite parts so
shiny and shiny dashboard we utilize
that all the time
pins plumber with uh apis
quite often used plotly
for the visualization because that's
more interactive
and of course our markdown for the
parameterized reports there
moving on we've got the package manager
and this
is really the unsung hero of everything
we do
because it seamlessly manages the
packages for us
and i had a quick look in in the year
that we've had it
we used 500 unique packages 8
000 package like downloads no one really
knows they're doing it it's all managed
for
us and and that's fantastic and there's
so many packages out there
uh provided for to answer every question
really
it's amazing we've also started creating
our own packages and that
integrates nicely into workbench uh we
we use some of the the tools within
there and we've started making packages
for our sql
connectivity our our um login and our
report writing so package manager
is it sits there doing its job
and it really is the unsung hero of it
all
hollywood would it be okay to ask you a
question that came from one of the
previous slides
yeah i'd i'd love to uh do you know
which side
um so someone had just asked um what
machine learning algorithms were used
for forecasting
i i'd have to hand that one off to
someone in my team certainly within some
of the forecasting that we're doing
uh we're utilizing uh profit facebook's
profit i think for some of the time
series forecasting
that is done but the ml that's done that
that is someone else in the team
i'm very much the uh the script writer
not the uh
data scientist here awesome thank you
put it in the chat as well if other
people have feedback too
sorry ellie thank you that's okay um
how is this changing so we've gone um
from from having no meters installed
no data to having huge data
and it's got more complex but we've got
more accurate as it's grown because
we we're now able to do so much more
with the data that we've got
um and as i said we've been able to grow
with the solution
we're at 13 million meters that will
move up to 50 million meters
250 million connected devices
and we will be able to grow with that
and and we've seen that already and
obviously been
stood up on the cloud as well it's very
much easier for us to
add memory or scale in any way that we
want and and that's been fantastic
as i said we've we've been paid now for
analytics so we're producing
the the standard the industry utilizes
to understand
how they're doing so it's not so much
about how we're doing but how are
industry doing
uh how they're utilizing our smart meter
solution
and we've become the trusted advisors
uh to our customers and our partners
our service providers and also our
stakeholders and
and they're now utilizing us more and
more
but of course what does that mean even
more
data questions they don't stop coming
and
uh we'll we'll keep having more and more
of those coming
um before i uh because i've switched pcs
i can't give you a live demo
of um some of our products but luckily i
did put them in as a
reserve slides so we can go on to those
in
in one moment but before i do i want to
say thanks to everyone out there who's
helped us
from our first days of trawling stack
overflow for answers
how do you do this how anyone writes any
code without stack overflow i don't
think it's possible
without but the whole community out
there the our community
is just amazing i think what gets
delivered
uh out there to people who are doing
stuff is incredible
the amount of help that is out there of
course i want to say thank you to
everyone at our studios they
they've been with us all our journey
longer than they actually know
because obviously once we downloaded
desktop we were starting using their
blogs and and all of the information
that they put out there but
they they've helped us with every step
of the way
and a big thank you to our customers who
ask the questions whether they're
internal or external
we get asked all the interesting
questions and you know we do
love to answer them and and my team
you'll see them online
midnight sort of coding away because
everyone loves just getting into that
data
and using the products we've got and and
and and just having fun really we we
really do have fun with the data
so i was at this point gonna show a live
demo
but i do have um
some of the uh the apps that i was going
to show so this is our forecasting app
obviously it's a a stationary
screenshot and and this is what uses
profit
for the time series uh analysis and
uh we we need within our industry to
forecast
where we're going how many devices are
going to be needed next year
and the year after but also we we have a
very
uh our comms team love to announce that
we're at our 15 millionth meter or
whatever
and we can see there's a forecast there
at the bottom that
for the 9th of september we'll probably
get given a chocolate bar within the
company for that
uh and we're 98 confident that we'll
we'll be hitting that date and generally
we're within one day
of where we're forecasting so this
forecasting helps us with outcomes but
also helps us with our ordering of the
comms hubs
and the other devices that are on our
network but also the infrastructure that
people are going to need to process
uh these messages the next uh
one this is a lovely app that i
like to use we get um a lot of questions
quite often from an mp so someone from
parliament
will come to us and say how is my
constituency doing have i got a lot of
connected homes it
it seems to be a repeated question so
we've got all that data available we can
map
all the installs to it and you can see
the drop downs on the left i could
choose to consist
constituencies and you can see there
where those two constituencies come out
and then the data at the bottom that
shows the number of households in
in that area and the number of connected
homes so
so this is utilized within the dcc a lot
for those questions that come in
external to the dcc how can we answer
them and and they appear live on the map
as well
it's actually lovely when i use it live
going on to our
um analytics that we utilize for our
sort of application support
we're running um many reports every day
and and we need to monitor them you can
see the average there's about 250
reports produced every day
and we've got an analytic tool that
allows us to not just see
how many they've produced also the
performance of them
and also it takes you to the logs for
them so it really is an application
support tool
that allows our 24x7 team to examine
what is happening
and we don't have to worry about going
in and checking logs it all happens
automatically
and finally i mentioned um uh monitoring
with a dashboard this is
the dashboard that uh monitors about
3000 metrics across our whole
infrastructure it's uh highly
configurable
but of you can see there that and i
fixed it in time so not to have any
commercially
sensitive data on there um we were
measuring about 1500 metrics two of them
um we we found were of interest and now
24 by 17
would have a look at that and there's
hyperlinks all through
that where you can see the history get a
nice plotly graph come up
and you can also um link across
to a help guide via our markdown
so uh apologies that those last four
weren't
interactive uh thank you for for bearing
with me during the uh
techno technological meltdown that i had
at the beginning i'm really pleased
to have got through that and to have got
here um
and and presented to you today i'm happy
to take any questions
[Music]